the scent is pretty prevalent you can
feel like the crusty sweat I'm gonna go
on one final jog with these briefs
before I pack them up and send them on
their way
hey my name's Phil I'm a hair stylist
I'm a music producer and I sell my used
underwear on the Internet I started
wearing these new underwear and so I was
going to get rid of old underwear and my
boyfriend suggested that I could sell
them online to people that follow me on
instagram because my Instagram is pretty
[ __ ] which I think like entices people
to pay for like sweaty underwear that I
workout in but the things I share on
Instagram are meant to like grab certain
people's attention at that moment but
what I'm working on doing is like
expanding that and kind of like getting
people interested in these other little
aspects of like what I do there's just
so much more to just like some [ __ ]
photos of me on Instagram like it's
important for me to create sex
positivity because we can in cultivate a
world where people are less judgmental
and more open-minded or at least
accepting and tolerating
I've got these American Apparel briefs
on and are pretty crusty at this point
going to take one final jog in them and
send them on their way and then
underneath I have this fishnet number
that is for a new order I recently
posted that I had some banned merciful
for my music project online but someone
sent me a DM and they're like hey I want
one of your band shirts but I want the
one that like you're wearing in the
photo and also like I want you to sweat
in it it's like totally yeah I'm cool
doing that anything else and they were
like yeah come on it a few times so I
was like all right so I have been
jerking off onto this shirt now I'm
going to work up one final sweat in it
before I send it to the person who is
requested that right now I will be
fulfilling three orders at once it takes
about a week a week and a half sometimes
two weeks to actually get underwear to a
point where like they actually smell
like something and it's a pretty
complicated process that involves
working out getting them all sweaty dry
out the underwear but like as soon as
they're dry I have to put them in a
ziplock baggy because that'll preserve
the Musk
so eventually they get to a point
usually after a week or two where I'm
like okay these seem like good enough
the most recent order from Andrew he put
I hope they smell like an intense
workout so like you know he just wants
them like really used like and that's my
intention with every one of them if I'm
like feeling extra sweaty at home I'll
grab them all like rub them on my nuts
very sweaty using can probably tell it
smells good enough to me so I think it's
a finished product this first pair is
going to Tim so I'm just gonna write him
like a nice little note you know make it
a little bit more personal a little
intimate have a good snip love
so this order is done I'm just gonna
drop that off with a post-office this
shirt still needs to dry out a little
bit they need to jizz on it a few more
times make it really worth their money
the thing is what I'm doing is not
harming anyone I'm offering something
that someone wants and it makes them
happy there's no insincere quality to
what I'm doing eliminating sex
negativity is really important because
there's a lot of people who are victims
are very real violence simply for
reasons of a sexual nature I'm part of a
community which is still I went we
attacked because of literally no reason
other than our sexual preference and I
think all of that lack of love and
compassion comes from sex negativity
[Music]
you